The variational quantum iggon solver or VQE is one of the earliest hybrid quantum classical algorithms and it's
interesting for several reasons. First, as we'll see in this video, it is a promising approach for some types of problems. Secondly, it's important
historically and has paved the way for many enhanced algorithms such as adapt VQE.
And finally, VQE is fairly simple. It's easy to understand what the quantum and classical computers do in this algorithm
and how they interact. There are four main components of a VQE calculation.
First, there's an operator, often a Hamiltonian, which we'll call H, that describes a property of the system that
you wish to optimize. Another way of saying this is that you're seeking the igen vector of this operator that
corresponds to the minimum IGEN value. We often call that igen vector the ground state.
Next, there's an anzz word meaning approach. This is a quantum circuit that prepares a quantum state approximating
the igen vector you're seeking. Really, the Anzots is a family of quantum circuits because some of the gates in
the Anzots are parameterized. That is, they are fed a parameter which we can vary. This family of quantum circuits
can prepare a family of quantum states approximating the ground state.
Next, we need an estimator, a means of estimating the expectation value of the operator H over the current variational
quantum state. Sometimes what we really care about is simply this expectation value, which we
call a cost function. Other times we care about a more complicated function that can still be written starting from
one or more expectation values.
Finally, we need a classical optimizer, an algorithm that varies parameters to try to minimize this cost function.
Let's outline the problem we want to solve and the general approach before addressing how quantum plays a role. We
can cast many optimization problems critical to science and industry as matrix value problems. Commonly, you
want the minimum igen value of your matrix and the igen vector that corresponds to it. The matrix H could be
a Hamiltonian describing the energy of a physical system. And the minimum igen value would be the ground state energy
E0 and the igen vector would be the corresponding quantum ground state often denoted SI sub0.
Or the matrix could describe a complicated cost function associated with combinatorial optimization problems
such as in logistics and the igen state s subopt would be an optimal solution of
the problem like a binary string labeling a cut in a graph of a distribution network. In practice it's
common to hear the term Hamiltonian used for all matrices of interest even outside the physical sciences. Let's say
we're interested in a matrix with n rows and n columns. Such problems can be solved quickly and exactly using
classical solvers for n up to a few hundred or thousand with no assumptions made about the matrix. For sparse
matrices, those with mostly zeros as entries, this can be much larger with n as high as a billion even on a laptop.
But for truly enormous problems that exceed these numbers, approximate or heristic methods are often required.
The larger the matrix and the less sparse, the less tractable the problem and the more clever tricks must be employed. Suppose your matrix is so
large that exact diagonalization is not an option. Suppose further that you know enough about your problem that you can
make some guesses about the overall structure of the target state and you want to probe states similar to your
initial guess to see if your cost or energy can be lowered further. This is a variational approach and it's one method
that is used when exact diagonalization is not an option using a classical computer. This would work as follows.
First, you make a guess state with some parameters theta that you will vary.
Although this initial guess could be random, that is not advisable. We want to use knowledge of the problem at hand
to tailor our guess as much as possible.
Second, we would calculate the expectation value of the operator with the system in that state.
Third, we would alter the variational parameters and repeat.
Fourth, we would use accumulated information about the landscape of possible states in your variational subspace to make better and better
guesses and approach the target state.
The variational principle guarantees that our variational state cannot yield an igen value lower than that of the
target ground state. So the lower the expectation value, the better our approximation of the ground state. Let's
talk about the difficulty of each step in this approach.
Setting or updating parameters is computationally easy. The difficulty there is in selecting useful physically
motivated initial parameters. Using accumulated information from prior iterations to update parameters in such
a way that you approach the ground state is non-trivial. But classical optimization algorithms exist that do
this quite efficiently. This classical optimization is only expensive because it may require many
iterations. In the worst case, the number of iterations may scale exponentially with n.
The most computationally expensive single step is almost certainly the expectation value of your matrix using a
given state. The n byn matrix must act on the n element vector which corresponds to order n squared
multiplication operations in the worst case. This must be done at each iteration of parameters. For extremely
large matrices, this has high computational cost. Now imagine relegating this portion of the
calculation to a quantum computer. Instead of calculating this expectation value, you estimate it by preparing the
state s of theta on the quantum computer using your variational anzots and then making measurements.
Let's pick that apart a bit. H is generally not easy to measure. For example, it could be made up of many
non-commuting poly x y and z operators.
But H can be written as a linear combination of terms H subalpha each of which is easily measurable. For example,
poly operators or groups of bitwise commuting poly operators. The
expectation value of H over the state S is the weighted sum of expectation values of the constituent terms H alpha.